einfach alle meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen runde main wo es wollt
mir alle dass ich das mal wieder
aufnehme allerdings gab es ein paar wir
die probleme und blauen block mit
christopher young minecraft und ich muss
hoffen nicht bedroht
zwei cent will dich nicht gespielt fünf
sekunden war die erste folge anderen
bistums
geht euch schon mal ein schwert das ist
ganz gut so und ich hab ich noch keinen
bogen dass du das problem
stan village doch die habe ich schon mal
gespielt hat die ja ich glaube das war
die es geht darum es gibt verschiedene
teams ich bin im team orange und sunrise
nicht übernehmen will
wir müssen halt die anderen teams
ausschalten das jetzt alles team orange
da wird schon mal ganz gut und es gibt
da noch drei andere teams ist hellblau
und dunkelblauer zwei andere teams
taktischen plan nicht drei andere
sondern insgesamt drei teams
es geht den 18 sekunden los das ist mein
team und irgendwie sehe ich nur orange
leute bisher vielleicht sind ja auch
erst so heißt es nicht nachher sind sie
alle auf einmal blau
okay das sind wirklich viele orange ja
dass noch ein blauer so willmann blauen
getötet okay das orange das genauso wie
ich übrigens ist die plötzlich tot
sondern jedes team hat 25 leben 25 24
leben hat jedes team acht menschen man
merkt dass sich das paar wochen nicht
gespielt habe jedes 224 leben und wenn
jetzt ein tipp 24
das ist teams nicht dann sind die halt
dann sind ja trotzdem alle weg also
nicht jeder darf 420 stärke das
komplette team läuft insgesamt 24 mal
sterben da geht doch vi
ich muss schnell weg
es geht ja nur auf mich drauf verändert
ich kann aber noch nicht einmal gott oh
gott oh gott da sind wir viel zu viele
leute ich tue etwas für das team und
locker weg nein also das ist wirklich
gut wenn ich jetzt weg laufe weiter
dadurch verliert unser team kein leben
dabei ist weglaufen es gar nicht so eine
blöde taktik
hhk die kommt zu dritt kolonie war sein
zu dritt kommen wir laufen brauche okay
wieso geht die zufrieden auf mich drauf
machen das betrifft mich unbedingt
können ich brauche neue kisten die welt
jetzt nur einen goldwert habe nix hilfe
kostet es gut mein schwert ruhig ihre
pfeile schießen das andere kiste mit dem
bogen von gesetzt der sog
jetzt im bogen hat der perfekte sniper
position er ist auch orange gut ich
brauche leute ist mit anderen farben
dass meine wars mittlerweile ist das
spielprinzip was wir somit am meisten
spaß macht orange mal etwas bogen oder
so auf dem bogen junge ich bombogen oder
so okay da hab ich endlich von daher
naja mein gott da geht's ab und hier
liegt im bogen okay hier ist jetzt nur
team orange das ist schon mal ganz gut
wenn jetzt können wir als team auf die
ganzen online gehen
das ist auch wieder so man das liegt
nicht aufkommen habt ihr das gesehen
läuft nur auf sich das auch tot
doch der kiste die ich hab ich mir eben
wenn ich glaub ich hab schon alles
mein gott
dass auch todt seine kiste
so könnten welche kommen das ladies
orange ich schließe mich den bitte ab
ok ok ok er hinterließ aber ob da noch
luft nach oben ist ja okay ich hatte
auch schon vorher nicht volle leben
jetzt muss ich wieder kisten kriegen
weil ich jetzt wieder nur in gold
schwert habe also ich das ganze prinzip
ganz gut
die im laub ist noch 14 leben oder
schaffen aufgabenfeld team gold sind wir
haben nur noch 300 schaffen wir nicht
die villa pcs einfach viel zu stark aber
ich dachte eigentlich ganz gut weil wir
da noch so schnell am anfang und warum
schießt du dich ab also wenn wir es
wirklich ein gutes team wenn wir zu
allen den beiden skype werden
dann könnten wir es nur neun teams
reset gambler wolf jakoby wir einen
anderen server eu bip q2 punkten wieder
zu minecraft dotcom firma beitreten
ich kannte mal ganz kurz so und hier
sind wir nun auf dem links drauf steht
mich vertippt ich hab meinen kräften
stadtmauer geschrieben ich habe schon
gewartet für die map flaggen islands
damit noch ein bisschen anderen web
sehen sie wieder ein paar leute die mich
kennen vielleicht kann ich einfach nicht
genug kraft machen nein ich bin nicht
autorisiert um nichts man muss nur mit
christoph reden ja das war ganz cool
diese sekunden geht die hunde los und
sie töten
ja dich wer dich töten ich kann mich
zwar nicht aber du hast witzigen skin
und ich werde schön und los geht's
ok ich hab' schon brustpanzer das schon
mal keller so gut wir haben jetzt noch
ich weiß gar nicht wo sind die zeit ist
bis man töten kann
scheiße ich ja keine kisten ich bin so
ein talent ich weiß nicht wie lange die
zeit ist bis man das pvp ist auch eine
minute mein handy hat gerade weil ich
eine nachricht bekommen habe von reply
to maine kommentare zuerst da ist ja
cool hat die community hat seht ihr die
kompakte jemand überwinden
da seht ihr wie ich hier mit euch
interagieren so bleiben team team
dunkelblau
hier ist nur team dunkelblau
da ist eine orange den faschismus ein
bisschen einfach so höre sind soll ich
das nicht so ganz verstanden
einfach alle die mit seinem team sind
über gott
ach mist da begreift er doch schade gut
ich immer wieder zu kaufen bei der
typische position
ja ich bin richtig gut was bürgern geht
christian abt da kommen die borussia
oh mein gott das war ein perfekter
schuss der auch
ja auch der auch
der auch über gott die skis kraftvoll
gut man geht weg wählt den die packen
den schon immer trüber das tötet mich an
aus beiden team der blau ist das
natürlich blöd jetzt auf die kiste ist
keine kiste oder da oben vielleicht
bleibt er tut sich sehr gut ich habe
gold schwert das ist ja schon mal etwas
aber das hat mit dem beim start erst mal
geben
die sind alle beim tvg stimmt dass eine
gelegt beim team ist auch die haben
prüfer fälle deswegen ziehen fast die
ganze zeit zu retten
danke so kurzem aufladen die karawane
zieht weiter
der kubaner hat wurst ich weiß nich
beendet dass die karawane zieht weiter
geht's weiter fleißig so ich habe wieder
ein bisschen leben zwar nicht voll
na gut da ist einer der ist vorausdenker
warum bringt er ist tot
töten die mich auch mal die 2
ich hab mich einfach die mich einfach so
angreifer oder für mich angreifen weil
ich komm kreft aber mir doch wurscht was
soll sich eingebildet rüberkommen aber
es ist so dass sie habe ich auch vorhin
gesehen dass da ein typ das sind ganz
ganz viele andere leute läuft einfach
nicht alle durch anstatt die daran zu
greifen die keine rüstung haben und geht
einfach nur für mich drauf roboter seine
flöte ids er kommt vom recht
aber wahrscheinlich schon dass ich nicht
so schreien da verhält ist wieder spät
in der nacht
ok es halb neun das ist spät aber wenn
alten trotzdem von daher ich bin
natürlich sehr rücksichtsvoll
ich habe getroffen
okay sind hiervon schießen das eine
oh mein gott jungs hat folgt mit bogen
ok jetzt nicht mehr habe dass er dort so
weite distanzen
wir sind ausgeschieden
dies ist das sowieso verpixelt weiter
liegt das eventuell ist wechseln soll
immer noch gute freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann will ich mich über
eine positive bewertung freund
schrecklich daumen hoch schrägstrich
like schreibt noch mal die kommentare
vita steve weitergeht die karawane zieht
weiter recht und ob eventuell der mine
war wollte server ip ist diego 1 oder 2
oder 3 oder irgendwie sowas punkt 11.11
uhr dort kommt dass ein paar andere apps
kann er ja aufschreiben und dann als 20